critics once again accusing border czar
kamala harris of going awol on the issue
that is expected to become the largest
migrant caravan ever as it heads north
nearly 10 000 migrants currently
gathering in mexico expected to make the
dangerous trek including at least 2 000
miners according to some of the migrants
the policies of the biden administration
offer a very big incentive to make the
journey
he promised
the army
the asian community he will help them
he will call title 42
it will help us having
real asylum
but now we need him to keep his promise
do you feel
like
president biden is friendlier to
migrants than president trump was
i think binding is friendly
jesse kamala harris is going to do an
event
but pretty much
nothing to do with the actual violent
problem
well i mean she showered these corrupt
central american
countries with cash
and then they stole the money and kept
sending the caravans north it's typical
liberalism right you just throw money at
a problem that keeps getting worse
didn't one of our correspondents
interview one of the presidents of one
of these central american countries and
the guy says yeah i haven't heard for
columbus for about a year yes she didn't
even call the guy they're supposed to be
diplomatic relations
here's how she's got to be so lazy
el presidente this is vice president
kamala harris
we sent you a lot of dinero how about
you stop the caravans thank you
move from carrot to stick stop the
caravan stop stealing the cash and maybe
they're going to be some consequences i
don't know what the consequences could
be that's not my job maybe send the cia
down there right they'll know what to do
and then there's the other thing too
you think letting a million illegals
into this country a year helps the
inflation problem
i mean that just explodes inflation that
increases demand destroys the dollar
i mean come on anybody with the brain
sees that how come she doesn't see that
she's making inflation worse go ahead
josh
wasn't it 253 000 the month in one month
it's not a million
we're talking two and a half million
this year look here's the thing you
think the woman as a prosecutor would
understand that if our money is going to
corrupt governments in central america
and she has been tasked with the idea of
finding out what the root causes of of
immigration are that she would do
exactly what you're talking about jesse
that is common sense but this woman is
lazy she is a lazy human being she
doesn't want to focus her message she
doesn't want to get out there she's been
in latin america for three i guess three
full days meanwhile jill biden was there
a few weeks ago six days in a row and
now they have it they have an end game
they want to try to get people to the
summit of america's she's calling
everybody and begging them to show up
and they won't show up and they won't
show i mean the woman is
she's more than a laughingstock she's
more than someone who's inept she is
lazy she doesn't deserve the job she
should just resign she's not doing
anything she's not going to resign right
she i think that she thinks she could be
the nominee in 2012 i don't think she's
lazy at all i think this is exactly what
she's just she's supposed to do which is
nothing uh they you know america says
build a wall and she goes a wall
a wall and then she left
we'll be right back i'm going to sound
very smart by using the phrase
decoupling and i'm not even sure i'm
going to use this the right way but i
think we should decouple the
impenetrable border with immigration
make it two separate things so like i'm
for i'm for having a bunch of people
come in they're great wonderful like
make sure they're vetted and stuff but
we should have this wall the problem is
the critics
they have lumped this all together so
when you talk about the wall they try to
go you don't want these people to come
in i'm from an immigrant family too oh
we all are a nation of immigrants that's
not about that we just want to have what
everybody else has which is a process
which is a wall not a wall but the wall
does do you think that the white house
has
a comprehension of what other people are
seeing like when you see the caravan and
remember also during trump some people
would say oh you're just making up the
caravan but like you're there with the
video and it's all happening and we know
this is going to take place throughout
the rest of the summer i don't even care
like forget the midterms it's like what
do they realize that they have a policy
problem because it seems like they don't
well i would think so so i did a
google search of everywhere that this is
being covered to see if it was being
covered from left to right and the most
informative article i found was in the
guardian which is about as left as you
can get talking about their number was
even higher than ours that it's up to 15
000 people that are part of this caravan
and uh 70 are women and children that
will definitely change the dynamic on
the border because
it had been being reported that it was
mostly single men that are coming in
women and children are obviously going
to be given preferential treatment but
this problem and
what these people are expressing as the
concerns of why they're leaving mexico
which is that there are no jobs there
for them is exactly the kind of
portfolio that kamala was charged with
this is a root cause problem right that
we have economic disaster not only where
they're coming from initially whether
that's guatemala or venezuela but that
in mexico is not an okay option so how
are we going to work this out with the
mexican president to make sure that
people are coming in are vetted properly
and also that mexico gets back on its
feet and is able to keep people that are
going to keep migrating north but i
don't i don't think that kamala harris
is lazy i think she really didn't want
this job this specific job and she likes
these other things and i'm not saying
that makes it okay but she wants to talk
about women's empowerment she wants to
talk about criminal justice reform and
this is so let her do it well she is
you're not saying what is she doing that
i'm not i'm not comfortable calling the
vice president of the united states of
america lazy i'm saying that her i know
i heard you do it like 10 times that's
why i'm saying that i think that
play the tape um
that this isn't this isn't what she
wants to do and unfortunately in life we
all get jobs that we don't want to do
president biden had this as vp as well
i'm sure that wasn't his top choice he'd
rather have just done gay marriage the
entire time and he ended up with this
portfolio and it's hard it's an
intractable problem that perhaps needs
to be deepened when you're the vice
president you have at your disposal you
could you could basically pick up the
phone you can call anybody that you want
you can hire anybody you want you get
all the help that you want and everybody
gets to make a choice you get to make a
choice every day what do you want to
focus on and if it's if you're going to
focus on women's empowerment in latin
america not the root causes of this
problem you will have more migrant
caravans i went to brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now